have you been using today young the dust
they ask that question every day in
stoke-on-trent they're dealing with the
fallout of a synthetic drug that you may
not have heard on monkey dust makes it
sound like a joke but up close it's
pretty ugly the man on top of the
building was on it
moments later hit Jones he landed on a
car and was then straight up grappling
with the police when we are trying
straight him it is he could be like
almost like trying to restrain the
Incredible Hulk of the strength is
unbelievable the police can't explain
why it's so concentrated around North
Staffordshire but this summer it's
reaching crisis points I think names his
plans percent of the people I know are
on it 90% yeah people I know is on dust
if not like more that's how bad it is
does anything any really anybody can do
and they are the fairly typical users
people with chaotic lifestyles
dependency issues and have no fixed
abode and they're picking up this drug
for two or three pounds ago it's cheaper
than a pint in this ambulance another
that feels no pain he's broken his arm
the bones sticking out just look at how
many people are needed to get him into a
any at the Royal Stoke Hospital first
time I ever got spat at was it was a
patient who had taken monkey dust
completely uncontrolled and I was trying
my desperate my hardest to to get a line
into them to be able to give them the
sedatives they needed not every patient
turns violent but those that do could be
a nightmare
whereas previously we've seen trucks of
recreation we're increasingly seeing
this as a drug of abuse it's a fairly
new agent and we've seen massively
increased use although we don't collect
the data anecdotally we know we're
dealing with a huge increase in numbers
and it's reached the point where
paramedics are now considering whether
they need body armor I had an instance
where I went to two children who were on
monkey dust and they were running in and
out of the traffic so not only are they
a danger to themselves they are a danger
to the public
it is a black an epidemic
and something does need to be done this
is your song
there is though no obvious solution
rehab doesn't always work and they can't
pinpoint where the supply is coming from
all they know is that they can't go on
like this
Parmenter Sky News North Staffordshire